as this bar now glides through the
darkness a sudden flash of light
illuminates over 20,000 helium-filled
soap bubbles suspended in the air
researchers contract the bubbles as they
swirl in the Owls wake and they're using
this to study the bird's flight in
unprecedented levels of detail revealing
unexpected ways in which birds generate
lift and reduce drag while gliding the
first task is to persuade the birds to
fly through the cloud of bubbles if they
can see the bubbles they try and avoid
them so the researchers have to snap the
lights on right at the last minute
that's the idea anyway when the birds do
glide through smoothly they leave
vortices swirling in the air behind them
the movement of each bubble is then
tracked and recorded by a computer to
visualize the airflow as expected the
researchers solve vortices spinning down
from the wingtips this helps provide
lift but the swirling bubbles revealed
something surprising a second pair of
vortices coming down from the tail
these also generate lift and because
they come from the tail the lift is
spread more evenly over the bird's body
reducing overall drag
this is different from the way something
like this toy plane works it has fixed
solid wings and uses its tail for
stabilization a tail that generated lift
would make it very unstable but birds
are able to constantly move and adjust
their bodies for stability so they can
use their tails to make extra lift and
decrease drag Engineers might be able to
copy this trick for use an aircraft that
actively stabilize themselves
it wouldn't work in the same way in
something like a passenger plane which
is much larger and faster but for small
slow flying craft like a gliding drone
designers could make good use of this
aerodynamic trick borrowed from birds
[Music]
you
[Music]